all right nathan we're here you ready to
do some hiking
keep our boys safe
luke and nate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're here on the
big island of hawaii
and we are going to be doing some
extreme back country camping
on a volcano yeah and
we might get to do a little fishing and
snorkeling too yeah
well it is a beautiful but hot day here
on the big island
and we are hiking across a lava flow
back in the 70s they had a whole bunch
of eruptions here and covered the
landscape and lava
and now just barely you get a few plants
growing up through the lava but
look at this terrain
yeah this is lava from when i was a kid
now we have about a nine mile hike
across this lava flow
to the ocean where we're gonna go try
and camp
on a remote isolated little cove and do
some fishing and snorkeling so we've got
a little over
nine miles to do today and it's gonna be
a doozy
and this is the longest hike nathan's
ever been on and you see the only way
you can tell the trail is there's piles
of rocks
leading off approximately the direction
that my gps is telling me
so this is definitely a hike where you'd
want a map at a compass or gps or
something can you see the next pile of
rocks nathan see look at this you can
see where the lava just came down here
and kind of piled up and slowly cooled
oh it looks like we might be heading
into the trees a little bit
look at this cool plant
it's like a dr seuss plant look at that
thing
one of the hardest parts about this hike
is that there's no fresh water
anywhere along the trail or at the
campsite it's pretty hot out here
so you can get in some real trouble if
you don't bring enough water so nathan's
just wearing a camel pack with
a bunch of water in his blankie and
about half the weight of my bag
is from water
you know we got a lot of hiking to do
today and a lot of hiking to do tomorrow
so we're going to stop
every 30 45 minutes and just take a
little three minute break
and uh we should get there no problem
[Music]
we can finally start to see the shore
and it's
long ways away
what's this
oh it's a guava
oh my goodness this is a white one
it's a little tart
these are all guava trees
yeah this one's a little more ripe
here wanna try peas
i love guava well that was an awesome
little surprise
i can see our campsite from here but
it's far away
you can see where the lava flowed down
the hill and went right into the ocean
look at these pretty flowers
look at all these little seeds are stuck
to my pants they're like made out of
velcro
they're it's white all right i got some
hawaiian snacks here including this bag
of macadamia nuts
they're super high in calories this one
bag is
1600 calories and
right here i have some linghi muy
covered strawberry gummy drops
the sugar will help give you a little
more energy
oh these are so good
okay buddy
you okay
nathan you okay bud
we've been hiking for three hours now
and we haven't seen
another single person the whole time and
we are out in the middle of nowhere
there is no one around here
all right three more miles
oh nathan did you cut your finger on
some grass
that grass is sharp you know nathan's
pretty tough he doesn't mind camping
without a tent or without a sleeping bag
in the snow but if he gets a cut he
better be camping with band-aids
you okay there all right seven miles
down
two more to go
jalapeno 1.6 miles we're getting close i
can
see it it's right there
oh my legs are getting gummy
that's a tank of water that services
backpackers but
i heard that they've been having drought
you have any water
rangers have been telling me they have
so much drought lately the water is
unreliable
and you can't drink it without treating
it i'm going to sleep like the dead
tonight
oh you fall again nathan's a trooper
he's fallen like
ten times nathan's wearing tommy's
hiking boots which are a bit
big for him and the poor guys he's
getting tired and starting to trip a bit
he's taking it like a champ though
tommy would love this place it's covered
in coconuts
look at this
yeah i totally might see a turtle oh
look at this this is beautiful
holy mackerel what a hike but man this
is beautiful
see i can see some little fish in there
look how beautiful that water is yeah we
don't want wet hiking boots tomorrow
hey come with me over here i brought our
snorkeling gear
we might just be able to snorkel right
in here this little sheltered lagoon
i could just sit here and lay on this
beach for hours
but we need to find a camping spot it is
going to get pitch black here in about
45 minutes
can barely see it but that palm tree
stump right there and there and there
are all carved with these faces on them
they look cool well this is typically
the windward side of the big
island they got a lot bigger waves here
and uh the ocean's a lot more uh
aggressive
yeah this water is no joke man you
wouldn't want to swim in this unless you
know what you're doing
hey let's go find a campsite
this is like a good spot let's camp
right here
this bag works really good on the wind
look at that
dry your socks off so that we have dry
socks for tomorrow to get hiking
looks like nathan still has about a
liter and a half of water he did a good
job rationing
oh you hungry buddy all right
we're gonna eat an mre chicken burrito
bowl
mre here i sure hope this is good cause
this is what we're eating
okay this is the chicken burrito bowl
there's a tortilla
uh some orange sugar powder drink mix
hot sauce
apple turnover toasted corn nuggets
spoon cheese spread you got a little
heater here
you can't bring camping fuel on planes
so
i just decided not to bring my stove at
all and just decided to bring mres for
this camp out
i'm gonna heat them up with a little bit
of water
precious precious water
all right there you go heater's starting
to work okay we're gonna sandwich the
tortilla and the chicken burrito bowl
with the heater
let that warm up it'll take about four
or five minutes
a little pack of gummy here's here's
your chicklet
all right that's feeling warm
we got like chicken rice and beans there
i really should eat this in the tent i'm
gonna get it all sandy
corn nuggets let's see what these are
i see look check this out
they're like corn nuts
like beans in mine
so my corn nuggets on here
you like them yeah beans taste good
actually
cool nuggets
you want to try an apple turnover
that smells good yep i don't take a bite
oh you take a bite
i i've got to get to bed i am absolutely
shot my legs are jelly and uh
i'm running a little low on water i
brought a gallon of water
and i've used up like 60 percent of it
that's something to worry about in the
morning
right now we are just in an absolutely
gorgeous spot
listening to the waves
i'm just gonna have a good night's rest
oh
i'm really proud of nathan this was much
harder of a hike than i expected and he
has done so well
he's been a trooper we're gonna pull out
my phone watch a movie or two
and i'll see you guys in the morning all
we need is
[Music]
well good morning it's about a quarter
to six and i'm watching the sun rise
over these palm trees
and i'm trying to do it away from the
tent so nathan can get a good night's
sleep because
he woke up a lot last night he woke up
and just started crying
after he'd been asleep for about an hour
and i asked him what was wrong if he had
a nightmare or something he said his
legs hurt his calves hurt
and uh so i robbed rubbed and massaged
his legs
for about 30 minutes and he seemed to
perk up and
and he went back to sleep and he slept
fine the rest of the night
but he got me really worried and i
stayed up a lot
i didn't get to sleep till like 1am
because i was just sitting there like
stewing as as parents often do i'm
worried because our return trip it's 9
miles which is long but we've got to go
uphill this time it's a a vertical climb
of
2700 feet it's an aggressive climb
but there is an alternative there's a
slightly longer trail that follows the
ocean
it's 11 miles but there's essentially no
vertical gain
if we could do that and just stop and
rest a lot
um i think that might be the safest way
to get home and i can just have becca
pick us up at that spot
instead of the one she was planning on
you know we've been communicating and i
gave her the gps coordinates as an
alternative and you know but i'm a
little worried honestly
um we took five and a half hours to go
nine miles downhill
um so and i think this is going to be an
eight-hour trip that's that's no joke
and we're going to have to keep him well
fed
and take lots of breaks and lots of
water so we'll see what happens
i brought my fishing gear and snorkel
gear
because i wanted to fish that cove and
snorkel in it and last night after we
put the camera away we took out our
headlamps
and there were fish jumping in the
lagoon and we saw an eel swimming up
onto the beach um and it looks just like
a really cool place
but honestly i'm i this isn't a joke
you know i i want to get my make sure my
boy is safe and i'm not gonna spend our
time and energy
doing that i'm gonna wait just a little
bit longer here i'm gonna start packing
up
we're gonna eat some breakfast and then
i think we're gonna start a really slow
return trip but we're gonna get to see
some cooler
stuff and uh make a lot of stops along
the way
so it should still be an interesting
video we'll we'll see what happens
i bought a bunch of shrimp and octopuses
fish bait
and i buried it in the sand because it
was getting a little raunchy and a
mongoose dug it up and pulled it into
the bushes
chewed a few pieces out of it and we go
dump this bait in the ocean
hey good morning i'm super
camping like this i really like these
camping quilts
i mean it was really hot when we went to
bed and we were practically sleeping
with nothing on us
and then it starts to get a little
chilly as the night goes on and you got
a little bit of a blanket and if it
really gets cold
you can wrap this around your mat and
use it like a sleeping bag they're just
really versatile in warm weather not to
mention they're lighter than a sleeping
bag
how are your legs are they sore yes they
can't
squat okay well we'll have to do some
stretches
how about here how does your calves feel
it holds you
on right here okay
well part of that's from going downhill
so you know when you go downhill you use
different muscles
all right for breakfast we have coconut
butter mochi
a hawaiian delicacy that's full of
calories and sugar
there you go buddy it's gooey mochi rice
with
coconut butter and loads of sugar it's
really good my wife calls it hawaiian
lambis bread it's a great trail snack
the water's getting really low
so becca dropped us off here and we went
all the way down here but instead of
going back
i think we should go and take this trail
all the way to there
all right buddy you ready all right
let's see how our legs are doing
let's we'll give them a little warm up
what a beautiful spot
you're not very tired oh good well i'm
glad you had a good rest then
crater road 11.3 miles
the trail is a bit shoddy here but i can
see the piles of rock
and a little faint game trail looking
thing going off it's good that we got an
early start so we can beat a lot of the
heat this way
just wish i knew this trail a little
better and done more research on this
one
but i've got a map of gps and cell
service so we'll be okay
you doing okay back there need your legs
hurt
you know sometimes when your legs are
sore if you work them a little bit they
start to feel better
you know don't hold my hand
we're just hiking through these tickets
but every once in a while there's a pile
of rocks so you can get on top of them
and
just have the most gorgeous view
nathan's legs are pretty gummy and i
don't blame them mine are feeling a
little too
so it seems like every 15 minutes we got
to stop and take a little rest
trying to each time we stop just take a
mouthful of water
take you know a little snack or
something and just try to keep our
energy up
and take a couple fruit snacks there you
know i've been setting my alarm for 15
minutes
gonna rest every 15.
look at this nade that
is a walking stick you can never find a
better walking stick than a bamboo
walking stick
15-minute break here just one sip of
water
and one little snack i can go a little
faster
oh good that's helping huh
looks like you're doing good buddy
you're sure hiking strong
i can see the campsite
see way down there there's a bunch of
palm trees
oh good job nathan
all right nine and a half miles to go
we're on the edge of two different lava
flows from the volcano kilauea
over here that's from the 1960s
and this lava flow over here is from the
1970s
you really can't see any trail on this
lava
so you've got to follow the piles of
rock
and this is a harsh environment there's
no soil
there's no groundwater no vegetation
this is intense got a little lava tube
right there and right there
nathan you did good that was a strong 15
minutes
my water is low
all right buddy it's the alarm i know
that one
still grab us chainsaw
ah we made it across the lava field
emoji break eater mochi
it's kind of shiny
you see these little push-ups where lava
came spurting out like a pimple
and just poured down here you can see a
little palm tree oasis
i think that's the campground that marks
our halfway point
only six miles to go
[Music]
all right little mre pizza
here
there we go got a emergency rations
shelf life pizza
a little bit of lunch while we're on the
trail
oh man those waves are huge don't fall
down there nathan
yeah we have a hard time getting you
back this little oasis is the apua
campsite
beach it's where i was originally
planning on hiking to
but i found out you can't fish there so
i thought i'll go a little further
and go to japan
i really regret that decision
it's beautiful though if i had to do it
over again
i would have brought an extra gallon of
water and we would have camped here
and only had a 12 mile hike instead of a
20 mile hike
i'm gonna take a break
it's the last of my clean water i am so
thirsty
i could go for a nice big bottle of
grizzwiz right about now
i think we can finally see the road
right there on the top of that mountain
i can see it
coming down oh put some extra spring in
your step to be able to see it
you see right there right there and
there
with lava crystals
here put your hand down they're kind of
sharp
oh they one of them just stabbed me in
the skin
but it's like little long bits of gold
and glass
oh it's kind of like touching fiberglass
don't don't touch it
ouch it looks like gold straw
but it's like a crystal from lava
a wave just came over the top of the
cliffs and sprayed me and felt
wonderful
[Music]
there's some sort of lava rock building
here somebody's put a lot of work in
building it this thing was huge
i'd like to explore it but some of these
are kind of like sacred sites
and if it is i don't want to mess with
it
ah we're at the home stretch probably
about
two to three miles left
well i lost about 40 pounds since april
so if i'd done this
hike in april this is what it would have
felt like oh
no wonder i was so tired all the time
hey luke yeah you working out yeah what
gym
people with kids don't go to gyms daddy
work out
there was a lot of promises made about
ice cream i've written checks that we
need to cash
you been a good friend hopefully serve
someone else well
nathan you just hiked 20 miles how do
you feel
so so exhausted yeah guys i am beyond
exhausted
we are gonna go get the biggest thing of
ice cream ever
and as many cold drinks as we could fit
in our stomach and i will see you guys
later make sure to click subscribe we
put on new videos
every saturday morning and if you guys
want to see
our whole two-week adventure here in
hawaii check the link
in the video description below
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching oh
thank you very much